hallo freunde der leichten unterhaltung
und willkommen bei meinem ersten let's
play und zwar let's play modells
soweit ja ich habe mich bei knuddels
angemeldet und hier seht ihr meinen
namen katze im transit natürlich so
loskill dein leben
das ist cool das ist klar wo gehen wir
dann zuerst rein flirt hat nicht mehr so
viele mitglieder also 90 82 69
ich weiß noch früher da war ich 12 13 14
das war so glaube ich die klubs hoch
zeit höchst mit ruhig zeit und da war
kann uns angemeldet aber noch ganz viel
geld glaubt wir gehen erst mal zu flirt
flirt video flirt videogames was macht
man mal wie die games video chill out
wie ich will darauf klicken aber ich
habe angst dass man mich dann sieht
nämlich traue mich nicht ich nicht drauf
wege erstmals befreien
ich habe nachrichten von raphael hallo
raphael hey hey du magst schreiben oder
so hasst kik war oder skype also leute
ich bin wirklich nicht von gestern aber
war ernsthaft hallo ich geb dir doch
nicht meine nummer kinder niemals die
nummer geben
okay machen ob das hier irgendetwas
führt
okay das wird jetzt hier komisch gottes
ist kompliziert hier wissen ihres online
wo warum hat deren so seht ihr das er
ist der einzige mit feuer bestimmt so
krasse tokio ich will nicht mit dir
schreiben ist gut
magst du gerne schreiben ja und lesen
auch die roten sind meine privaten
nachricht auch in der seite krieg und
der ton nervt ja super aus wir gehen das
spiel oder nein wir schreibt mit james
mit james schreibe großklubs der tipp
mit james vega james machte so viel
werbung times jetzt blicke ich gar nicht
mehr durch da kann man nichts machen
katzen tauchanzug liebst du je melo hat
gerade richtig lust auf einen zirkus mit
dir zum kuss erwidern aber mallow
wir kennen uns doch noch gar nicht soll
ich ihn zurück zum küssen gesehen mal
zurück explodiert ist mein computer
dafür ist es schon zu spät
du hast so lange überlegt wenn jemand
nicht zum küssen will dann musst du ihn
ja bitte zurück du bist blöd dass nun
nicht kennt ist sprichst du mit mir
jetzt geht's los
ok james voll langweilig wir gehen mal
nach hamburg
hallo hamburg was ist los bei euch geht
es euch gut mein haben wir denn hier so
hosen elliott team aus border collie
skicross harburger leider echt mehr
wartet das so nahe kommen wie gangster
player 12 30 uhr dj jeremy vita guck mal
solche namen wollte ich lesen sweet love
du befindest dich in einer kleinstadt
knuddel hausen im königreich knuddel
onyia das reich ist vom bösen kreaturen
überlaufen kannst du uns retten
möchtest du in den kampf ziehen hier
klicken oder dich erst in der stadt
besser ausrüsten hier klicken
dann hätten kannst du dir mit show
anschauen wenn du deine kurze anleitung
zum spiel lesen möchtest verwendet
das ist ein richtiges spiel nein danke
okay lasst uns eine runde spielen
lasst uns spielen mau mau poker es uns
pokerspielen dieses turnier anmelden
warte auf fünf weitere spieler
wo bin ich wenn ich da bin ich mir
beginnt gleich
hallo ich heiße ich will gold derzeit
aber ich gehe ich hab mich jetzt
entschieden dass wir auf eine andere
seite gehen und zwar spiele jetzt gibt
es das noch
jetzt anmelden kostenlos an die
kostenlosen web bestellt oder ihr seht
meine e-mail-adresse nicht
hier können sie nicht sehen
ok dann benutze ich ein passwort das ein
bisschen länger ist und das gleiche noch
mal ich bin kein roboter vielleicht doch
ein bild machen da jetzt wieder
ich werde wahrscheinlich gleich wieder
erinnern müssten aber egal so das ist
ein hammer warum lebst du ja ich bin
viel heißt wie heißt dann kann ich mit
namen ausdenken okay mein name ist
ich nenne mich mal meine haarfarbe ist
nein ich habe jetzt eine neue haarfarbe
das kommt hin dass du bist mein gesicht
ist so mein gesicht ist so leicht braun
nein nein ich glaube das ist das ist es
das ist es oder dass ich trage gerne so
was die auswahl ist so sims 1 ein
laszives topf auch frei ich glaube auch
dass ich im echten leben nicht machen
kann gebe ich jetzt hier aus zu hause
ich wende roxy koloss ahmadi vermindern
also ich nehme ein so ein urteil und
rock farbe ist so liga events welche
farbe das ist doch mal
doch die ok vanessa ballerstedt viele
deinen ersten raum um loszulegen später
kannst du gratis weitere räume stelle
als ich sie schon so esoterisch aus dann
sollte ich den unternehmen glaube ich
die spieler haben gute leute es liegt
nicht an dir sondern mehr cool also das
bin ich das ist mein typ der gerade
willkommen im habe ich bin frank der
hotelmanager komm herein
ok du aufregend in den kommenden tagen
werde ich die viele wertvolle geschenke
geben
ich werde mal geräusche hier ist dein
erstes geschenk ein kühlschrank der
immer voll ist du kannst ihn in deinem
im winter finden stelle deinen neuen
prüfung beim bund ab dann doppelklick
darauf und erfrischungsgetränke bekommen
ich hätte mich kleines gut damit unser
penthouse mit
und jetzt möchte ich dass du hier
reingeht
zudem wollte so lasset explorers the
world ganz viele menschen spielen das
noch leute oder sind das jetzt
es gibt noch leute die haben spielen sie
cool aussieht werden
hier sind die coolen das ist jetzt mich
zu den kundendienst sich bitte hin nicht
so peinlich setz dich denken was guckst
du habe ich gerade niemanden bei habbo
hotel provoziert
lustig sein
aushalten aber kamera ich mach ein foto
von uns für die erinnerung ist auch
langweilig da habe ich mir echt was habe
ich nur gedacht meinvz
es gibt meinvz
also schreibt ein bitte in die
kommentare ob er wusste das ist mein vz
gib ich wusste es nicht studivz klappte
da ist noch jemand ist noch jemand bei
studivz oder wer-kennt-wen studivz nach
märz schluss und wir sehen uns dann wald
und eine tobi ich bin professioneller
geworden vielleicht irgendwann mal
wieder und muss dann und wir sehen uns
im nächsten video und tschaikowsky was
mache ich wenn ich fertig bin najef
stopp oder auf pause